saisie à 6h pourriez demander un
animateur de prendre votre fils dans
quelques années sur l'émission de télé
un chroniqueur bien ce que je pourrais à
oui oui pour une méthode de votre avion
et je vous demanderai à vous ah c'est
vrai il le fera pas bonjour a pas
beaucoup de choix j'imagine mais oui je
j'accepterai alors j'espère qu'un jour
vous animerez ouaf ouaf ci sera le
deuxième mois pour moi ce qui serait
très bien comme ça beau jour dans ouaf
ouaf
non c'est ce qui sera très bientôt être
chroniqueur de votre fils ah oui là ça
commence à faire mal pour le fils
d'ailleurs qu'à croiser benjamin
castaldi n'ont hélas hier oui il est
comme vous une mamie il m'a dit m'a
frappé c'est vrai mais c'est vrai bien
sûr et une passion non qu'on va ferait
pas charrier quand même je n'ai pas
répondu il a 8 ans et fils du patron
d'abord d'un enfant donc les gens là les
autorités l'avaient oui il vous dit
bonjour y est mais en plus ils visent le
genou comme vous qu'il est un peu il a
peu changé une fois j'avais croisé
j'avais crié ça vanne sur quoi il
faisait ses vannes j'étais désolé et du
coup je crois je veux lui je suis désolé
d'avoir grillé tavannes il dit ça
m'étonne pas tu es une banane
[Rires]
il a planqué basket quand on était en
train de se changer
j'ai ça m'a pris 45 minutes pour la
retrouver c'est très amusant
[Rires]
[ __ ] c'est vrai ces trois histoires je
la vends car je suis fan de lui sauvera
les fans simplement j'ai passé mon pote
aulas et son camp
bien sûr